election day just five days away now and
president donald trump continues to
question the integrity of the election
so the i-team has been digging deeper
into that issue and found
answers from one law enforcement agency
we don't often hear about
vanessa murphy has the story that you'll
only see here on 8 news now
president donald trump in bullhead city
arizona wednesday
continued to undermine confidence in the
election process in nevada
particularly mail-in ballots they're an
option for
all active registered voters in the
state during the covid 19 pandemic
we're a little concerned with all those
ballots floating around in nevada
got a lot of ballots floating around in
nevada an issue his campaign has been
pushing
voter fraud from your department's
perspective
is voter fraud widespread through the
mail
no as of right now i am unaware of any
credible reports of any voter fraud
being committed through the mail
and that's something postal inspector
trevor hudson would look into
if it involves you know any tampering of
the mail then we definitely
would have a part in that investigation
he's part of a team in las vegas
we're federal law enforcement agencies
so you know we you know we carry guns we
make arrests we serve search warrants
it's an agency more people are becoming
familiar with
after its role in the arrest of former
trump adviser steve bannon
and in the lead-up to november 3rd one
of our missions as a postal inspector is
to protect the security of the mail
so that's something that we're trying to
do and something that we we do all the
time so that's
something we'll continue to do through
the election five days from the election
the u.s attorney's office sent eight
news now a news release from the
department of justice
about protecting voter rights and about
resources being used to
investigate election fraud now in
addition to the postal inspector telling
us
there are no credible reports of voter
fraud
i recently talked with the head of the
fbi of las vegas
he also said voter fraud is not
widespread
nevada has secure voting machines and he
wants voters
to feel confident vanessa murphy 8 news
now
the trump campaign has also filed
lawsuits to try and stop
counting here in clark county and for
personal information of election workers
now those are both working through their
way through the courts and if you
believe you've been the victim of a
postal related crime
you can file a report by calling the
number here at the bottom of your screen
which is 877-876-2455